[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren es ist nun schon mehr als ein
jahr
dass wir in dieser pandemie leben mehr
als ein jahr
dass der größte teil meiner arbeit als
bundeskanzlerin der arbeit der
bundesregierung der des bundestages der
landesregierung der landtage der
kreistage und verwaltung mit dieser
einen aufgabe zu tun hat unser land
durch diese katastrophe und wieder in
bessere zeiten zu führen
seit dem ausbruch der pandemie stemmen
wir uns alle gemeinsam gegen das virus
es ist eine wirkliche nationale
kraftanstrengung die jeden erfasst und
die jeden betrifft alte wie junge und
kinder
stadt und land politik verwaltung
bildung wirtschaft kultur sport kirchen
unser aller leben und zusammenleben
es ist ein jahr an dem wir gemeinsam
gelernt haben wie das virus funktioniert
und was gegen das virus funktioniert
lernen heißt nicht von anfang an immer
alles richtig zu machen
auch einschätzungen zu korrigieren so
wie wir es zum beispiel bei den
empfehlungen für das tragen von masken
getan haben aber gerade deswegen sage
ich auch wenn wir gerade in einer
schwierigen phase stecken und viele
menschen das gefühl haben das wirklich
nicht mehr lange auszuhalten
gerade deswegen sage ich auch wir haben
in diesem jahr der pandemie ein sehr
großes stück des so schweren weges
hinter uns gebracht und dabei hatten und
haben wir das ziel unsere gesundheit
system nicht zu überlasten
höchstbelastung der menschen und der
kapazitäten in den intensiv medizin
sie gab es und gibt es leider
und wir können unseren ärzten und ärzten
und pflegerinnen und pflegern gar nicht
oft genug für alle ihren einsatz danken
aber eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems die konnten wir
vermeiden
gott sei dank der mit schweren folgen
einer infektion in die klinik muss der
bekommt überall in deutschland die
versorgung er braucht wir sehen an
vielen orten der welt wie wenig
selbstverständlich diese aussage ist und
wir können gemeinsam froh darüber sein
dabei weiß ich dass das was wir
gemeinsam im kampf gegen die ausbreitung
des virus erreicht haben einen hohen
preis gekostet hat und unverändert
kostet ich vergesse keinen einzigen tag
was die notwendigen maßnahmen für jeden
bürger jede bürgerin bedeuten eine in
der bundesrepublik so nie erlebte
zeitweilige gravierende einschränkung
der freiheit schwere persönliche
belastungen einsamkeit wirtschaftliche
sorgen existenzängste das vergesse ich
keinen einzigen tag alle maßnahmen sind
gemäss den regeln unserer demokratie
geschlossen worden
das macht das rechtmäßig aber ich weiß
sehr wohl als demokratie sind wir auch
verpflichtet diese einschränkung keinen
tag länger aufrecht zu erhalten als
nötig und sie aufzuheben wenn ihre
begründung entfällt und genau das ist
das ziel der bundesregierung und ich
weiß auch des ganzen
und sagen meine damen und herren ich
sprach von dem was wir gemeinsam
erreicht haben
dazu gehört dass die erste welle der
pandemie im frühjahr 2020 deutschland
weit weniger hart getroffen hat als
viele andere in europa und weltweit
dem folgt ein sommer in dem wir im
rückblick gesehen wieder leichter leben
konnten bei instituten die heute
traumhaft erscheinen drei oder vier
ansteckungen über sieben tage auf 100000
einwohner dann und das müssen wir zu den
leben zählen dann waren wir nicht
vorsichtig genug und nicht schnell genug
wir haben auf die anzeichen der zweiten
welle und die warnungen verschiedener
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hin nicht früh und nicht konsequent
genug
das öffentliche leben wieder
heruntergefahren bei meiner letzten
regierungserklärung hier vor ihnen das
war am 26 november 2020 hatten wir
wochen dramatischen exponentiellen
wachstums der infektionszahlen hinter
uns diese steile wachstum haben wir
schließlich beenden können aber noch bis
in den januar dieses jahres hinein
verbreitet sich das virus viel zu
schnell und viel zu unkontrolliert eine
folge dessen bin ich sicher von
zögerlichen vorgehen ausgangs des
sommers und im herbst
heute stehen wir was die
infektionszahlen anbelangt weit besser
da die notwendige trendumkehr die ich am
26 november erhofft hatte ist gelungen
die zahl der neuinfektionen geht seit
geraumer zeit zurück ebenso die zahl der
aktiven corona fälle und die zahl der
koma
in den intensivstationen und in aller
vorsicht sage ich auch die schlimmste
die traurigste zahl von allen die der
menschen die jeden tag an corona sterben
scheint endlich wieder zu sinken
wenigstens werden keine neuen
höchststände mehr erreicht diese
verstorbenen es sind jetzt weit mehr als
60.000 menschen das sind unsere mütter
väter kinder verwandte freunde die wir
nicht bewahren konnten die trauer um sie
und mit ihrem hinterbliebenen steht
immer im raum denn wir entscheidungen in
dieser pandemie treffen
das sind wir ihnen schuldig dann gibt es
noch eine positive entwicklung auf die
bei meiner letzten regierungserklärung
nur hoffen konnte die aber keineswegs
gewiss war
die impfstoffe sind da das ist ein
wendepunkt in der pandemie er wurde dank
der arbeit fantastischer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in rekordgeschwindigkeit erreicht
wir haben uns für den europäischen weg
der verhandlungen der beschaffung wird
der verteilung der impfstoffe und gegen
nur zulassungen entschieden
dazu stehe ich in der schwersten krise
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg halten wir
europäer zusammen politisch wie auch
epidemiologisch überall in der
europäischen union wird jetzt die imk
ein kleines oder wirtschaftsschwäche
russland muss sich hinten anstellen der
einsatz europäischer mittel wie auch die
abnahmegarantien die deutschland
übernommen hat hat im übrigen bei antec
zb den einstieg in die massenproduktion
seines impfstoffs ermöglicht natürlich
meine damen und herren verstehe ich dass
der start der impfkampagne in
deutschland gleichwohl zunächst viele
menschen enttäuscht hat
denn die hoffnungen die am ende hängen
sind riesig und jeder von uns und auch
ich habe noch diese hoffnung auch ganz
persönlich wenn dann am anfang zwar als
zugesagter menge aber gleichwohl nur
verhältnismäßig wenige dosen zur
verfügung stehen müssen sehr
schwerwiegende entscheidungen getroffen
werden
bei ihnen helfen die empfehlungen der
ständigen impfkommission
auf ihrer grundlage haben wir
entschieden zuerst die verletzlichsten
und gefährdeten zu impfen die alten
menschen im pflege- und sonstigen
einrichtungen sowie die ärzte und
pflegekräfte die sich um sie und um die
korona patienten kümmert kümmern
heute haben wir 80 prozent aller
menschen in pflegeheimen und weit über
eine million menschen in medizin und
pflege mindestens ihre erste impfung
bekommen dass es überaus wichtig und das
bedeutet schutz wo er am allernötigsten
gebraucht wird jede woche jeden monat
werden nun millionen weitere impfdosen
bringen und immer mehr menschen werden
diesen schutz bekommen und bis zum ende
des sommers jeder der möchte dieses ziel
wollen der angesichts der uns zugesagten
mengen an
impfstoffen und zwar an impfstoffen für
uns schon zugelassenen produzenten auch
erreichen und es bleibt natürlich auch
weiterhin ganz klar so wie die
bundesregierung sich zu beginn der
verhandlung mit den impfstoffherstellern
finanziell engagiert hat so werden wir
sie auch weiterhin dabei unterstützen wo
immer das möglich ist neue
produktionsstätten zu finden und die
produktion weiter hoch zu fahren was von
ganz besonderer bedeutung auch im blick
auf die mutationen ist gestern hat
biontech die impfstoffproduktion in
marburg gestartet die bundesregierung
hat eine task force gebildet zu den
fragen des impfens die auch beständig
tagen wird das impfen kommt also immer
mehr in schwung die infektionszahlen
sind auf dem weg nach unten andere
wichtige indikatoren auch und wenn das
das ganze bild wäre dann sehen sie mich
hier heute recht zuversichtlich bei
allen schwierigkeiten da ist aber es war
nichts war zwar noch nicht ganz sichtbar
aber immer erkennbarer
eine große gefahr für diesen guten weg
auf dem wir uns befinden und das ist
eine sehr reale gefahr in form von
mutationen des virus die sich gebildet
haben und zwar so gebildet haben dass
sie zu aggressiveren virusvarianten
geführt haben es war natürlich
irgendwann damit zu rechnen und es kann
auch in zukunft weitere unerfreuliche
entwicklung geben
jetzt haben wir es mit im wesentlichen
drei relevanten mutationen zu tun der
englischen bei uns am weitesten
verbreitet der südafrikanischen der
brasilianischen noch ist nicht alles aus
erforscht aber wir tun gut daran an den
annahmen viele expertinnen und experten
aus dem in und ausland nicht zu zweifeln
wenn sie uns erklären alle drei
mutationen sind deutlich aggressiver
also ansteckender übertragen sich
leichter als das ursprungsvirus und wie
es bei deren ist die mutanten setzten
sich aufgrund genau diese eigenschaften
früher oder später gegen die vorherige
variante durch so ist es in eigenen
europäischen ländern bereits geschehen
die daraufhin eine zeitweilig
dramatische zunahme an infektionsfällen
erlebten mit allen katastrophalen
auswirkungen auf die gesundheitssysteme
diese mutationen sind inzwischen auch in
deutschland nachgewiesen worden in der
letzten januarwoche sind haben einen
teil von 5,7 prozent ein
wir werden in den nächsten tagen neue
daten bekommen
am häufigsten kommt bei uns die
englische variante vor expertinnen und
experten erklären uns dass es eben nur
eine frage der zeit sein bis diese
mutationen dann auch die oberhand
gewinnen und das ursprungsvirus
verdrängen und darauf müssen wir uns
einstellen
trotz sinkender instanzen die wir im
augenblick haben müssen wir einfach
wissen dass sich darunter eine neue
virusvariante aufbaut und das wir sehr
sehr achtsam sein müssen nicht immer
weiter nicht wieder ins exponentielle
wachstum zu kommen deshalb deshalb mag
ja sein dass es ihnen muss gefällt aber
bisher mit der realität leben und dann
auch die richtigen antworten sind
was hilft uns dabei wir haben eine
situation in der die impfkampagne immer
schneller an läuft aber sie wird uns in
den nächsten monaten noch nicht den
gemeinschafts schutz bieten sondern nur
individuellen schutz den wir brauchen
die erwartung vieler menschen ist
natürlich dass jetzt wieder die zeit sei
einen klaren weg von öffnungen und
erleichterungen aufzuzeigen und wir
wissen dass die gefahr der mutationen
uns die erfolge wieder kaputt machen
können indem eben die höhere nährwerte
uns in ein exponentielles wachstum
zurückfallen lassen
das ist die ausgangssituation vor der
wir gestern zusammen gekommen sind und
und länder und wir haben alle gemeinsam
diese schwierige widersprüchliche lage
empfunden
und wir haben vor diesem hintergrund
maßnahmen vereinbart und zwar bis zum 7
märz die allermeisten der beschränkten
maßnahmen müssen konsequent beibehalten
werden es geht immer und immer wieder um
die reduzierung von kontakten in dem wir
private zusammenkünfte auf den eigenen
hausstand und eine weitere person
beschränken indem wir medizinische
masken die jetzt möglicherweise
ausreichend vorhanden sind tragen und
zwar in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln in
geschäften in innenräumen wie hier im
deutschen bundestag
und das gilt auch für die arbeitswelt zu
fern mehr als eine person im raum ist
privatreisen und besucher auch von
verwandten sind weiter zu unterlassen
und das arbeiten im home office muss wo
immer möglich durchgesetzt werden
und ich will noch einmal an die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitgeber wirklich
appellieren das ist ein probates mittel
um kontakte zu reduzieren
die privat die privaten haushalte tragen
viel zur bekämpfung dieser panne bei
auch hier muss sozusagen die wirtschaft
damals home office möglich macht auch
wirklich dazu greifen und natürlich
waren die erwartungen an den gestrigen
tag weniger was wird beibehalten sondern
was wird verändert und wir waren uns
alle einig dass die priorität
kinderbetreuung und grundschulen haben
denn die folgewirkung von wochenlang
schließung der einrichtung sind
natürlich da und spürbar und die
anspannung der eltern ist groß
und trotzdem hätte ich mir an dieser
stelle gewünscht dass wir auch hier
entlang der instanz entscheiden aber ich
habe auch akzeptiert dass es eine
eigenständige kultur hat der länder gibt
vielleicht das oberste prinzip der
länder
und deshalb haben werden die länder sehr
verantwortlich in eigener hoheit
entscheiden wie sie das genau machen es
wird werden einige schulen vielleicht
schon nächste woche öffnen die
allermeisten am 22 aber immer nur die
grundschulen und die kinderbetreuung
in richtung die grundschulen im wechsel
unterricht mit vielen hygienemaßnahmen
das will ich hier ausdrücklich sagen
damit haben wir haben dann über einen
weiteren öffnung schritt gesprochen ob
erster märz werden die friseure öffnen
wir haben am ersten für den ersten märz
die gute aussicht dass wir wir haben für
den ersten märz die gute aussicht dass
wir eine instanz von 50 bundesweit
erreichen können
wir haben heute eine inzidenz von 64,2
nach den aussagen des robert koch
instituts und wir haben dann über die
weiteren öffnungszeiten gesprochen
das ist natürlich das was jetzt von
größtem interesse ist und ich will hier
ausdrücklich sagen dass ich sehr
unterstütze dass wir uns bei diesen
weiteren öffnung schritten auch im blick
auf die unsicherheiten der neuen
mutationen entschieden haben nicht daten
zu nennen sondern infektionszahlen also
instanzen zu nehmen und da sagt man sich
einander gut das gibt mir doch keine
planungssicherheit
aber wir gehen sozusagen mit dem virus
in einem kampf das ist unser gegner und
das virus richtet sich nicht nach daten
sondern das virus richtet sich nach
infektionszahlen und auch fragen die
sich die infektion ausbreitet deshalb
haben wir den nächsten weiteren öffnung
schritt für eine inzidenz von 35 ins
auge gefasst manche sagen wo kommt denn
diese instanzen wieder her
sie wissen 50 haben wir als einen punkt
im paragrafen 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes festgelegt ab
dem sehr sehr weitreichende maßnahmen
beschlossen werden kann und bei 35 wenn
man jetzt mal von unten kommt bereits
weitreichende massen
das heißt der punkt 40 30 er ins ident
ist der punkt an dem ich einen ersten
öffnungs schritt gehen kann und hier
haben wir gemeinsam beschlossen
das den einzelhandel galerien museen und
körpernah dienstleistungen umfassen soll
ich glaube das ist ein richtiger und
wichtiger ausblick und dann kommt es wie
geht es weiter mit dem nächsten öffnungs
schritten
da muss ich ihnen folgendes sagen ja
bund und länder werden darüber beraten
und wir haben auch die verschiedenen
bereiche natürlich genannt da geht es
dann immer um die frage
kontakt beschränkungen im privaten raum
da wird es auch um die frage der schulen
in den höheren klassen gehen
da wird es um die frage geben sport in
gruppen um freizeitgestaltung dann
gastronomie und hotels das wird ein
stufenweiser prozess seien von dem heute
noch nicht genau sagt es jedenfalls aus
meiner sicht bei welcher instituts für
was machen können weil wir jetzt erstmal
schauen müssen wie weit er die kontakt
nachverfolgung auch wirklich schaffen
wie weit wir mit der korona war nicht
mit der aufstockung der gesundheitsämter
mit letzterem test strategien all das
liegt ja heute vor wie weit wir auch mit
unseren bessere schutzmaßnahmen dann
immer weitere lockerungen zu lassen
können ohne wieder ins exponentielle
wachstum zu verfallen
und ich will ihnen sagen mein ziel ist
dass wir eben die neue welle die kommen
könnte wenn das neue virus oberhand
gewinnt das wir dir keinen raum geben
und nicht wieder einen solchen
exponentiellen anstieg von fallzahlen
haben sondern dass wir alles tun um die
kontrolle der kontakt nach verfolgung zu
behalten und damit keine große dritte
welle auslöste
das bedeutet aber auch dass wir
zusammen sein müssen ich glaube nicht
dass das hin und her einmal öffnen
einmal wieder schließen für die menschen
mehr berechenbarkeit bringt als ein paar
tage länger zu warten und sich den
überblick darüber zu verschaffen
dass man in einem kontinuierlichen
prozess wirklich aus
und das ging rauf und das genau ist doch
die das genau ist doch die spannung auch
unter der wir alle leben und die spüre
ich genauso wie sie hat davon können sie
ausgehen wer möchte nicht gute
nachrichten verkünden jeder weiß ich
habe es am anfang gesagt wie der die
menschen leiden und trotzdem glaube ich
war es gestern richtig sich auf die
schule
die friseure und dann den ersten
eröffnungsshow seine beiden anderen
bestimmten incidents zu konzentrieren
und so werden wir auch weitermachen
meine damen und herren das was wir
gestern vereinbart haben davon bin ich
überzeugt ist geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig es gibt insbesondere
auch weiterhin kein milderes mittel als
konsequente kontakt beschränkung in
allen genannten bereichen um das
infektionsgeschehen nachhaltig und
behörden auf einem beherrschbaren niveau
zu bringen und doch dort zu halten und
ich glaube am gestrigen tag gab es noch
eine wichtige botschaft die alle auch
mit interesse und freude zur kenntnis
genommen haben denn die sehnlichst
erwarteten anträge für die
überbrückungshilfe drei können seit
gestern gestellt werden
es wird abschlag sagen schauen sie ich
weiß wie
viele menschen auf das geld warten ich
weiß welche not ist und wie viele
menschen keine liquidität mehr
ich weiß wie der einzelhandel leidet und
an rauch aber eines will ich an dieser
stelle dann auch sagen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
bundesfinanzminister haben versprochen
dass im februar die anträge gestellt
werden können und dass diese anträge
damit abschlagszahlungen beantwortet
werden dass ab märz die auszahlung durch
die länder erfolgen
wir haben heute dem 11 februar gestern
war der zehnte thema das was versprochen
wurde es eingehalten und trotzdem ist es
für die betroffene ende wahnsinnig lange
zeit gewesen und ich bin froh dass es so
ist wie es ist aber ein wichtiger und
weniger werbepost präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
dieser winter ist hart da draußen
genauso wie in dem was er mit unserem
leben macht aber wir haben unser ziel
klar vor augen immer klarer wir sind
nicht mehr sehr weit von
infektionszahlen entfernt die uns
schritt und schritt um schritt wieder
öffnungen und freiheiten ermöglichen
können weil neben infektionsketten
wieder nachverfolgt werden können und
weil die überlassung des
gesundheitssystems verhindert wird all
die anstrengungen und entbehrungen jetzt
noch einmal bis zum 7 märz fortzusetzen
um die mutation klein zu halten und
hoffentlich deutlich unter die 7 tage
instanz von 50 zu kommen das ist aus
meiner sicht die anstrengung wird es
geht immer wieder darum dass wir weiter
deutlich sinkenden zahlen haben wir
müssen ausdauernd sein und wir müssen
geduldig sein und ich weiß dass an einem
solchen tag wie heute keine
echte bittet aber die menschen können
auf einen start setzten auf eine
bundesregierung die alles was sinnvoll
und möglich ist in bewegung setzen um
denen zu helfen die hilfe brauchen damit
sie über diese so schwere zeit kommen am
ende das ist meine feste überzeugung und
das ist auch mein auftrag den ich bis
zum letzten tag meiner amtszeit erfüllen
werde
am ende können wir es gemeinsam schaffen
diese pandemie zu besiegen und unser
land wieder in bessere zeiten zu führen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]